[Musique]
cher passagers au nom du gouverneur de
notre charmante colonies bienvenue dans
le cadre des troisièmes entretien du
patrimoine de l'océan indien aux pays de
la zone sont actuellement en visite à la
réunion afin de proposer des idées
autour du thème patrimoine mise en
valeur et perspectives touristiques
ce dimanche 2 octobre une visite
expérientiel du lazaret de la grande
chaloupe a été réalisé votre navire look
sus fait l'objet d'une mise en
quarantaine suite atteint suite à la
détection d'un cas de rougeole pour
votre bien est celui de notre patrie
créole vous séjournerez du 8 au 23
janvier au sein du lazaret l'idée
c'était déjà de permettre une immersion
dans la réunion du 19e siècle à l'époque
effectivement lille a besoin de
manoeuvre est de présenter le lieu qui
témoigne un petit peu de de l'accueil
d'une nouvelle population
ce soit des gens qui sont venus par
choix ou des gens qui sont venus
contraint le lazaret propriété du
département est un site historique qui
retrace le peuplement de la réunion
un lieu qui conjugue patrimoine et
attractivité touristique
c'est important à travers cette visite
du lazaret que nos concitoyens aient
aussi des invités de les poires
connaissent l'histoire de la réunion
l'histoire du peuplement de la réunion
qui est passé par ce site du lazaret une
visite guidée expérientiel du lazaret
pour appréhender au mieux la
conservation du patrimoine un moment
enrichissant qui a séduit les hôtes
voient le brassage des civilisations qui
sont passés dans le temps ici donc c'est
un lieu passionnant lieu qui mérite
effectivement lieu de mémoire qui mérite
ses investissements ses travaux
franchement je vous dise c'est très
grave y est
c'était vraiment une visite très très et
ducasse ionel pour moi et en même temps
ça me donne beaucoup l'envié de
continuer le travail que j'ai commencé à
l'union parce que ça ressemble aussi un
peu comme chez nous beaucoup beaucoup
l'aspect culturel traditionnel qu'il
faut à tout prix une visite et des
entretiens afin de mettre en place des
stratégies de valorisation entre
conservation développement et de
gouvernance
[Musique]